so you want to know how to start a worm
farm
well good you're in the right place
because that is what we're talking about
today here at hates at good life
my name is natalie i'm a backyard farmer
here in san diego california
and today i'm going to share with you
our latest design which is our worm farm
i'm going to share with you how to build
a worm farm what is a worm farm i love
worms so much but more importantly i'm
going to show you how i built this warm
farm and how you can build your own worm
farm too
so thanks for joining me today i'm so
glad you're here
without further ado let's hop in so
first off i know that getting started
with a new form of composting can be
kind of intimidating which is
why after years of doing it myself i
finally wrote these two books
this is my free quick start guide which
you can follow it will help you get
started
with setting up your worm farm super
quick and easy and this is my other worm
farm ebook which is available in our
etsy shop it
is super comprehensive it takes you
through setup maintenance
harvest ways to use your casting so
whether you're just getting started or
you want some more information i want to
draw these
worm farming resources to your attention
because i think they're going to prove
very valuable to you
another thing we should talk about very
briefly is i was checking my analytics
and some of you be watching
but not subscribing so if you're not
subscribed to this channel yet
please hit that subscribe button and the
notification bell as well it's a way to
support us for free and it helps our
channel grow other ways you can support
us for free are by
hitting the thumbs up and leaving us a
comment those also help us a lot so
thank you in advance for that now i know
a lot of you are here to see how i built
this
and hopefully editing natalie has
figured out how to add chapters go ahead
and click through the chapters that you
want to see
if you want to skip to certain parts of
this video i'll also leave
timestamps in the show notes down below
if you're here watching this video you
probably already know this but let's
talk about what is a worm farm
a worm farm is another way of saying a
vermicompost setup it's a way to use
worms
to make compost free fertilizer at home
into sustainability a worm farm is
another great way to reduce your waste
and carbon footprint
but for me as a gardener and somebody
who's interested in homesteading and
regenerative agriculture a worm farm is
so much more than that for me a worm
farm is a way that we steward our dream
of having livestock one day
as we learn to take care of this very
low maintenance livestock if you want to
call it that
worm farm is a way that we reduce our
carbon footprint and we
do a lot of composting out here with our
food scraps contrary to popular belief
though worm farms
don't need as much food scraps as you
think they do
so it's not the only way that we compost
our food here but it is
a way that we can compost leftover food
scraps like apple cores
or cucumber skins or whatever it may be
and as a gardener and a backyard farmer
a worm farm is a way that i make compost
for free at home
and it's so much better than anything
that you can buy in store which we'll
talk about at the end of this video so
if you're interested in learning
more about the benefits of a worm farm
for your farm or garden stay tuned
because we'll talk about that at the end
because
i don't want to bore you guys i know why
you're here you're here to see how to
build this so you can compost in your
apartment or you can compost in the city
but i just wanted to cover like what is
a worm farm and why
might it be beneficial to you there are
so many reasons but for us it gets down
to
being more sustainable stewarding our
dreams and having a way
to have wonderful bioavailable nutrients
ready to go for our garden
and now i can introduce you to our worm
farm worm farm
internet internet worm farm this is our
worm farm and it's very simple
i inherited this system off of steven of
nature's always right so if you want to
see like the entire original video of
this worm farm setup you can
check that out in the links up above and
down below
no matter what type of worm farm you go
with you want to make sure that you've
got proper
air flow and drainage because too dry or
too wet is not
a good environment for worms want their
environment to be something like that of
a damp sponge not too cold not too dry
somewhere right in between and this has
been a great setup to achieve that so
steven did a really good job setting up
these bins
and i can just kind of give you a brief
overview here is that
these bins essentially have a lot of
holes around the top not near the bottom
so the worms don't escape
but near the top are spaced anywhere
between one to two inches apart
and he's drilled on the top of these
lids around the top of these bins
and as well as on the bottom so like i
mentioned this system was
given to me by steven of nature's always
right he's got a great channel if you
guys don't know that channel you should
definitely go check it out
i redesigned it to work better for our
space because his original design was
much longer
and it was just harder to accommodate in
our semi-urban
setting whereas for him it worked fine
on his farm
but for us i just needed something a
little bit more compact and i wanted
something that would also give me the
ability to regenerate soil below
this worm bin so as you can see there is
room below these worm bins to place this
entire setup over
soil and as i water these worm bins and
as leachate drains through
we'll be able to make our own very
healthy
soil biome below this setup and that was
something that was important to me
so that's why this setup is designed
like that it's a little bit more space
efficient and it will help us regenerate
soil below the bins
all right let's talk worm farm supplies
if you need any supplies
for making your worm farm and you'd like
to support our channel for free please
consider using the links related to this
episode because when you shop through
those links
we are paid a small commission at no
additional cost to you it's a really
easy way to support our channel for free
so thank you in advance so
for the structure of this project i used
wood that i found in the back of lowe's
and not like behind the building like in
the building they had disassembled some
pallets or something
and i was able to find wood that was
only heat treated
if you're going to use pallet wood make
sure you're only using heat treated wood
the stamp says ht on there i believe and
you can look up the different stamps
but anyway so i found some so i found
some heat treated wood
that was once used i believe in some
kind of a pallet and they had
disassembled it and just left it in the
back of the lumber section i said can i
take this
and they said yes so i got my wood for
free something to consider
sometimes you can find stuff in the back
of like home depot or lowe's or your
local hardware center that they don't
want
they don't need they need to get rid of
it that's what i did and
i got a lot of my materials for free i
also used deck screws which i happen to
have on hand from the
thousands of other projects that i've
done around here i personally do like to
pre-drill
even though supposedly with deck screws
you don't have to pre-drill
i generally always pre-drill my projects
just to ensure that i'm not going to
crack the wood which brings me to the
next point
i also used drill bits and an electric
drill for this project
and i also used a staple gun quarter
inch staples
and quarter inch mesh and a note
i would have loved to have used corner
clamps on this project but i have since
returned the corner clamps to our
neighbors and i don't have any corner
clamps until santa comes or until i make
it big on youtube
there you go no corner clamps for me
right now but i highly recommend them
they're a great tool to have on hand if
you're going to build anything that you
want to be super square
i've used them in the past i miss them
one day i'll have my own and it will be
wonderful
but for now i don't have corner clamps
but if you're wanting to make this
project i highly recommend you get some
corner clamps the lighting's getting a
little funky on me out here but onward
we press
one day very soon we'll have our farm
and lush green pasture
and lots of different lighting and angle
setups but for now we're gonna throw
some hands of good life on this
shift a little bit and continue talking
about worm farms
[Music]
so step number one to making this worm
farm i made the frames
to make the frames i just made sure that
everything was level
and screwed four pieces of wood together
measuring about 22
by 36 inches then i stapled on some
quarter inch mesh
i overlapped the mesh to create
additional support in the center of the
frame and i stapled those sheets
in place with one staple about one to
two inches apart
[Music]
it was time to add the legs of this worm
farm this is where things got a little
tricky without corner clamps but i found
a way
[Music]
i made initial drill points
and once i was happy with the stability
and the levelness of the project
i made the second drill points which
solidified the whole thing
[Music]
now at this point you could add a little
bit of wood glue which i did but i
didn't get it on film
that just makes everything a little bit
more stable
[Music]
to create the totes just use a quarter
inch drill bit and drill all the way
around
every two inches or so you can see how
these were originally built
over on steven's channel nature's always
right as these were once his bins but
the idea is simple
airflow drainage holes and you're good
to go then you can remove the lid of one
container and combine the totes and
voila you have a worm farm
[Music]
let's talk about what's actually going
to go in the bins
you can follow this guide it's pretty
simple it breaks it all down for you
it's like a nice little map
the first thing that you want to do is
you want to lay down some kind of piece
of cardboard or several pieces of
newspaper just along the drainage holes
on the bottom
then you're going to add your browns
water those down with some chlorine-free
water
then you're going to add your food
scraps and your grit water that down a
little bit you're going to add your
compost
soil bedding peat moss whatever you're
using for the worms to kind of start
their life in
add another layer of browns on top of
that that's
basically it you can repeat that process
several times in my quick start guide i
show you how to repeat it three times
more than that is probably excessive so
i would recommend
just start with you know your three
basic layers but if you're feeling like
you're really wanting to get into this
and you want a lot of castings quick
like feel free to add multiple layers
it's really up to you there's a lot of
freedom in this
don't worry your worms will figure it
out
[Music]
so we've covered all the basics of like
how to build a worm farm but what is the
process
of being a worm farmer actually look
like i'm gonna break this down for you
very simply very quickly okay this is my
worm farming process
zelda worm farm set up worm farm wait
two to three months harvest castings
brew tea apply to the leaves drench the
roots
add remaining castings and worms to soil
if desired
yield abundance like so simple
i promised you guys we would talk a
little bit about worm farm benefits now
if you're here you likely already know
all of this but in case you don't i
figured it's worth mentioning and
talking a little bit about
starting a worm farm allows you to make
fertilizer
at home essentially for free which is
pretty amazing if you ask me
a worm farm is a great solution for
composting
in an apartment or composting in the
city it offers
so many ways to compost and it doesn't
smell
it's great no smell when your worm farm
is healthy there is no smell so you
don't have to worry about stinking up
your apartment
or your townhouse or anything like that
like worm farms
are great for so many reasons composting
without smell
i love it worm castings are super
balanced fertilizers so if you know
anything about npk
like you want to make sure that you're
adding the right nutrients at the right
times for your plants
you don't have to worry about burning
your plants with worm castings because
they're
super bioavailable and they're actually
protected in this little mucous membrane
that makes them
slightly a little bit like a slow
release fertilizer
it's not something that's going to be
released into the environment all at
once it's something that will
eventually leech out its nutrients over
time you will notice the benefits right
away but again i've never experienced
burning my plants with worm castings and
i attribute that to the fact that they
are very balanced
their nature is like slow release
fertilizer which is pretty cool
worm castings and worm tea help prevent
disease i cannot
tell you the difference that i saw in my
garden this year using foliar feeding
worm tea techniques in the garden like
seriously
my garden exploded we had so many less
pests and disease so i saw a huge
difference in that alone
and i cannot recommend it enough again
check out the video if you want to know
more
worm farming is so fun for everybody of
all ages but especially kids if you have
kids and you want to teach them about
sustainability
about composting worm farming is a great
way to get them into learning how to be
a better steward of their environment
learning how to be more sustainable
just learning about worms in general is
pretty cool if you ask me
i'm kind of a worm nerd though so maybe
i'm biased but again it's a great
project for kids
and it's something that's like safe and
fun for the whole family so if you're
into that
another thing to consider is that your
kids might really enjoy having a warm
farm as well
[Music]
that's it i hope you guys have enjoyed
today's video thank you so much for
joining me
i like to make lots of videos from our
homestead helping you guys
throw some hats a good life on things
make the most of it where you are
bloom where you're planted keep dreaming
keep working
towards those dreams because they're
absolutely there for a reason
we need as many people as possible right
now saying yes to regenerative farm
dreams and yes to gardening and yes to
growing food
because the times are bleak and we must
continue to say yes to those things so
if you're one of those people
good anya keep dreaming big keep making
the most of your small space
keep putting one foot in front of the
next i'm so proud of you keep going
we're here to root for you and thank you
for rooting for us as well of course if
you want more support when it comes to
vermicomposting and worm farming i check
out the whole playlist that i'm
developing here on this channel
i hope it will offer a lot of value to
you and offer you some new ideas when it
comes to composting
in a small space in a way that doesn't
smell in a way that's fun and in a way
that is great for your garden want to
support our channel for free hit that
thumbs up
subscribe hit the bell leave us a
comment i'd love to hear from you thanks
so much for joining us today you guys
and i'll catch you guys in the next one
bye
[Music]